[MUSIC PLAYING]
Almost every process in the
body is the result of a
carefully orchestrated cascade
of events, elements that must
be coordinated to come together
to give a very
precisely amplified response.
Now amongst the most well
studied or most carefully
studied of those cascades is
that which leads to blood
coagulation.
How injury or exposure to
foreign surfaces leads to the
formation of a stable
blood clot is
essential to our survival.
And medicine's understanding of
that process, how to stop
blood clotting when you don't
want it to or keep the process
going when you do, has
been essential to
our ability to intervene.
But also, it's given us an
insight into important but
rare disease processes.
When a blood vessel becomes
injured, the first thing that
happens are that platelets run
in to try and plug the hole.
And platelets are just
broken down bits of
old red blood cell.
But that, on its own,
isn't enough.
You need to throw down this
kind of biological chicken
wire on top of it to
stabilise the clot.
And that stuff is strands of
fibrin, a glycoprotein which
is the result of the coagulation
cascade.
And if you imagine that this
domino is one of the elements
of that cascade, you can see
that all of them need to come
together perfectly.
And if any part of that chain is
interrupted, then you don't
get the perfect clot.
Perhaps the best known of the
genetic disorders of bleeding
is haemophilia in which an
absence of factor VIII leads
to sometimes life threatening
haemorrhage.
But there are others and one
in particular, know as von
Willebrand's disease in which
the absence of a specific
biomolecule leads to problems
with prolonged bleeding.
Now that disease was first
discovered in 1926 by a
physician researcher called
Eric von Willebrand.
And he, confronted with
a patient-- a
young girl, in fact--
who had problems with extensive
bleeding, went on to
trace her family line and found
that this was a disease
that ran in her family.
And so having discovered that
disease, it would be several
decades before we understood
DNA and inheritance well
enough to trace it down to
a single gene that lay on
chromosome 12.
And that gene bears von
Willebrand's name.
[MUSIC PLAYING]